.
AND ALSO WONDER WHO IS GOING TO
BE GETTING RICH OFF OF THIS?
>> Reporter: AS RUSSIAN TROOPS
POURED ACROSS UKRAINE'S BORDER,
KICKING OFF THE RUSSIAN INVASION
IN LATE FEBRUARY, SOMETHING ELSE
WAS HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME
IN NEW YORK.
THE STOCK PRICES OF THE BIGGEST
U.S. WEAPONS MANUFACTURERS
SPIKED.
MANY EVENTUALLY CLIMBING TO
THEIR HIGHEST POINT IN YEARS.
>> WAR IS GOOD BUSINESS FOR
PARTS OF THE ECONOMY.
HISTORICALLY.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE DEFENSE
CONTRACTORS CYNICALLY WANT IT.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THESE
COMPANIES, AND THEY'RE AS HEART
BROKEN BY THE WAR IN UKRAINE AS
THE NEXT PERSON.
BUT WAR IS GOOD BUSINESS.
>> Reporter: THE LATEST AMERICAN
WEAPONS SHIPMENT TO UKRAINE
INCLUDE SYSTEMS LIKE SCORES OF
155 MILLIMETER HOW WITIZERS AND
JAVELINS AND STINGERS GOING TO
UKRAINE'S BATTLEFIELD.
>> SOMETIMES WE WILL SPEAK
SOFTLY AND CARRY A LARGE
JAVELIN, BECAUSE WE'RE SENDING
THOSE IN, AS WELL.
>> Reporter: JAVELINS ARE MADE
IN PART BY RAYTHEON, WHOSE CEO
SAID THEY EXPECT TO BENEFIT FOR
THE NEED TO REPLENISH U.S.
STOCKS.
>> WE DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR MAKING
THESE WEAPONS.
THE FACT IS, THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE IN DETERRING AND
DEALING WITH THE EFFECT THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE SEEING TODAY.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL HAVE TO
REPLENISH IT AND SEE A BUSINESS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
>> Reporter: RAYTHEON AND SEVEN
OTHER COMPANIES MET WITH THE
PENTAGON ABOUT NOT JUST
SUPPLYING UKRAINE, BUT
REPLENISHING U.S. AND ALLIED
INVENTORIES.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DENY THAT
THESE KINDS OF CONFLICTS CAN
HELP CERTAIN CONFLICTS.
IT'S THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION.
BUT WE SHOULD BE GLAD TO THE
HELP WE WANT TO HELP UKRAINE,
THAT WE HAVE THE BASE TO PRODUCE
THIS STUFF WITH SUCH HIGH
QUALITY.
>> Reporter: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ALONE HAS
CONTRIBUTED ALMOST $3.5 BILLION
OF MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE, IN
THE TWO MONTHS OF RUSSIA'S WAR.
COMPARED TO THE PENTAGON'S 2023
REQUESTED BUDGET FOR WEAPONS,
THAT'S JUST 1.2%.
CRITICS SAY THE PENTAGON AND
CONTRACTORS COULD USE THE
UKRAINE CONFLICT TO JUSTIFY
BIGGER BUDGETS AND MORE WEAPONS
SALES.
>> MY CONCERN IS, WILL IT BE AT
A REASONABLE COST, WILL THE
CONTRACTORS GOUGE THE TAXPAYER,
AND ALSO WILL THERE BE ANCILLARY
CHANGES IN OUR MILITARY SPENDING
THAT DON'T REALLY RELATE TO
UKRAINE BUT ARE USED BECAUSE OF
THE FEAR RELATED TO THE RUSSIAN
INVASION TO SPEND ON THINGS THAT
REALLY DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE DEFENSE OF EUROPE.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE ALSO
CONCERNS ABOUT WHERE THE
BILLIONS OF WEAPONS ARE GOING.
ONCE THEY CROSSED THE BORDER
INTO UKRAINE, OFFICIALS SAY THE
U.S. HAS NO WAY TO TRACK THE
WEAPONS.
NOR, OF COURSE, WHERE THEY END
UP IN THE LONG RUN.
>> ONCE IT GETS INTO UKRAINIAN
HANDS, IT'S UP TO THE ARMED
FORCES TO DECIDE WHERE IT GOES,
WHAT UNIT GETS IT, WHEN, IF IT'S
STORED AT ALL TEMPORARILY.
THAT IS UP TO THE UKRAINIANS TO
DECIDE, NOT THE UNITED STATES.
>> Reporter: IN THE $33 BILLION
OF FUNDING THAT JOE BIDEN
REQUESTED FOR UKRAINE, OVER A
THIRD OF IT, $11.4 BILLION, WAS
ALLOCATED TO REPLENISHING THE
U.S. WEAPONS INVENTORY, AND FOR
UKRAINE TO BUY MORE WEAPONS.
THAT'S WHERE THIS NEW BUSINESS
FOR THESE WEAPONS COMPANY ALSO